zeke is as capable as anybody i know
uh
you know he's an experienced player he's
been a really good player for us he
knows our system of football i don't
think there'll be a lot of learning
there
um he's a smart guy he's an instinctive
guy so
but again that's a hypothetical we're
just focused on the guys we have right
now we're gonna go practice as well as
we can to prepare the right way to play
the giants
jason garrett making sure he says
absolutely nothing that will get him
called to the principal's office because
it's jerry and steven jones who say all
the important things about ezekiel
elliott and look it was a crazy few days
i feel like this deal is going to get
done today let me just fast forward to
the bottom line they need this guy on
sunday they've made enough progress over
the past two or three days to tell me
this is getting done the reports have
been back and forth all over the place
but peter do you agree with me that it
just feels inevitable that at some point
today we're gonna find out that they
have worked out a contract with ezekiel
elliott and he'll be on the field sunday
against the giants
i'm so glad i don't cover contracts
anymore mike i leave it to you and to
others uh i you know that's the benefit
of being 62 and not caring about that
but
but i will just say this i will say this
i disagree with you that they need him
sunday night against the new york giants
i i mean do you think that in the first
three weeks of this season
giants washington miami
i mean you know right now the dallas
cowboys have the ability if they choose
and i have no idea if they're going to
choose to do it to basically say hey
listen you want this final five six
eight percent of benefit on your
contract we're not going to give it to
you i mean and again i don't know that
they're doing that and it sounds like
they're not but i think that they'd be
totally fine the first three weeks of
this season without elliott oh yeah
that they know they might not be that's
why they're panicking right now going oh
gosh we don't want to be the ones to
blame here if we start 0-102
again
dallas is very talented to you are you
serious are you serious i'm very
starting with the giants and washington
yeah the giants stephen
yes you had your time to talk you're
gonna have to wait for me now okay the
giants defensive front seven big it's
physical the cowboys have shown us
nothing in the ezekiel area they're not
the greatest show on turf they've showed
us nothing that they're capable of being
consistent or explosive on offense
without ezekiel elliott so i gotta see
it to believe it my hopes are like yours
peter you think oh there's enough talent
maybe they change the oc that'll help
out amari cooper's there i get you but
it's still this is a kellen moore who's
worked for the offensive coordinator
they just fired and that's really all he
knows that's all he's ever been around
except for one year with joe lombardi in
detroit so i don't know how extensive or
crazy this offense is gonna look
different that's my big question not to
push back against you too much just a
little bit that's all i'm trying to do
there here's the thing and here's the
thing i don't care about owen 2. i care
about 0-1 right and i think the giants
can beat them without ezekiel they play
them very well in the cowboys home
stadium remember they've always played
them well there and you lose that first
game at home to the giants and you get
to week 17 and you're figuring out are
we going to win the division are we
going to be the five seed are we going
to maybe have that loss is going to
haunt you and you can pin it right on
not having ezekiel so i think the fact
that there's been
peter so much
talk and negotiation the past few days
they want to get this done i think they
are going to get it done
i mean it sounds like they are i'm just
saying that if there's one time in the
course of the year where you can afford
to be without him for a couple of weeks
and to have him fresher for the last 13
games i don't think it'd be the worst
thing in the world well me and mike
don't agree with you so the hell with
you on a tuesday morning i got the
giants if zeke isn't there but i think
he'll be there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports